[Music]
Hey, I'm Will and with Noble Locksmith
and you're watching my YouTube channel,
Car Key Wizard. I'm an automotive
locksmith and while I definitely don't
know it all, I have learned some tricks
along the way that I hope will help you
while you're out in the field. One thing
you can do to help me out though would
be to subscribe to my channel. And if
you like my videos, leave a comment or
ask a question and I'll get back to you
as soon as I can. I make a lot of
videos, so if there's something you'd
like to learn more about or a video
you'd like to see on a car we're working
on, just let me know in the comments and
I'll put it up as soon as I can. Thanks,
and I hope you enjoy watching my videos.
[Music]
Good morning, Noble Locksmith fam and
the rest of the locksmith world out
there. We're making a new key, spare key
for a 23 Chrysler Pacifica. Um, these
are good contracts that a lot of people
don't think about, but the mobility type
of van outfitters,
um, you know, they get a key, they get a
car in, they're going to outfit it for
the customer, and then they always want
that customer to have two keys. So, we
get a lot of business from these guys.
Um, but this is, uh, easiest way to do
this one's a starport.
Um,
so you're going to go to this pillar,
uh, B-pillar.
I'm wrong. Ron will correct me. And
you're going to pop this bad boy open.
And, tada. Now, I don't have the uh,
Smart Pro on my van. I have the Altel,
which is fine. Um, you can use the
Altel. problem is with the Altel
or not a problem. Um,
you got to have power on the OBD
port,
which is not a problem. Um, so what you
got to do
is
hook
kind of sucks. You got to have a you got
to have an extension basically. Um and
they sell these on Amazon. You don't
have to do this with the Smart Pro. Of
course, you got to do it with the auto.
So,
turn that car around. I hope it's long
enough. Yeah. Yeah, it should be because
it's uh we'll see. We're going to we're
going to make it long. Oh, yeah. Plenty
long.
So, I have this long extension here.
Um,
and we're going to we're going to plug
our AltEl
Maxi Flash
uh into this cord. And of course, since
this is Bluetooth, we're just going to
set it up front.
So, as you can see, I've got my Maxi
Flash plugged in up there. And then I'm
going to plug in my star port.
It's a little freaking hole.
Hold on a second. Star port is all
twisted up. How in the hell?
So, the other way to do this is with the
12 plus 8 cable. Um, I think we have a
video of that up.
So, I got to find out how to figure out
how to get way down in there. I might
have to pull this
further off cuz Yeah, I can't. Let me
see if I can move some stuff around,
which means
break some No, I won't do that.
All right.
Oh,
I'm going to pull some trim back
so we can get in there cuz you have to
plug into that green one.
It's kind of annoying. You got the green
plugs plugging into the
white block and the white one's plugging
into the green, but you got to go into
that green one right there. And um
so we're going to plug right there. I'm
going to set my camera back here
for a second
so I can do this.
Two hands.
All right. So we got that plugged in
there.
Smack the hell out of my temple. I'm
going have a headache now. Now we can
just sit back here and relax.
We got both keys with us. Of course,
we've only got to program one in.
So, we're going to go to EMO.
We're going to
accept it. We're going to go to
Chrysler.
We'll do an auto selection.
It fails a lot on Mopar.
All right. So, we pulled the VIN.
If it fails, that's okay. We'll go back
and do a manual selection.
All right. It found it. So that's what
we're working on. 23 Pacifica. We'll
click okay. All right. Now we want to go
to the control unit.
We're going to
pause to take this call. I'll be right
back. And we're back. So first thing
we're going to do is read a mobilizer
password and try the can. Um turn
ignition off and hazards on. So turn
that on. Get those hazards on
and click okay.
Configuring.
Now, I'm in the habit of taking a
picture of the pin code when it comes
back. I've just had a few times where
you don't take it and then you got to
enter it in, you forget it. And man,
that sucks. And then the thing you
always try to do is you try to go back
and get it again and then you start
having some issue with the car and you
can't get the damn PIN code back again.
Um, so I'm going to let this run for a
second. Uh, as soon as it gets done,
I'll be back.
All right, we got our password. So,
we're going to click okay. Now, just so
you know,
if you've got a Smart Pro and you've got
your Starport connector, absolutely do
this with the Smart Pro. No question. uh
much easier, much quicker. Um and we
have Smart Pro. I just have it on my
van. Um I don't usually do these jobs. I
do most of the European stuff, but my
other guy came here this morning, did a
job, and he went down to Carvana to do
some jobs, and I was right down the
street when they called back for a
second car. Um so, we're knocking this
one out now. But this is also
anformational channel uh for YouTube.
So, maybe you don't have a Smart Pro and
you got an Altel, Altel 508, maybe. Um,
well, this is going to do it. So, we're
going to escape back out of there. We're
going to go to our keyless system.
Key learning. Number of keys. Always
check first.
So, we got three.
That's good. When we're done, we should
have four. So, we're going to go to key
learning. Make sure the ignition is off.
We're going to click yes. We want to
learn the key. And here's my key. So,
that time it saved the password and put
it in for us. Alt's pretty good about
that. Smart pro also.
So, hold the proximity key near the
start button.
So, we're going to press okay.
And then we're just going to hit the
unlock button
till we hear the doors.
And you just keep hitting it.
I like to move it around.
Hold my tongue to the left. All right.
So, we just got locked. So, that only
took about 75 clicks.
And so, learning successful. Do we want
to learn the next key? No, we're good.
So, now we're go to number of keys.
Double check. Number keys four. So, now
you're done. So, uh, just to go back
over it real quick with the AllTel, you
do have to have power
to the star port. Um, Smart Pro, you
don't. So, we've got our extension
jumper that goes into the OBD. Then, we
plug our our pass through uh connector
into the extender. And then our extender
runs all the way back here to our star
port. Um, and then we we do everything
on the Altail. So, this is a lot easier
when you got your star port right over
here on the kick panel. These are the
only ones that have it back here, the
the the van. So, that's how you do
those. Uh, you know, I cut the keys for
the customer already. Lease you that bad
boy. And, uh, you're good. So, thanks
for watching. Uh, if you have any
questions or comments, just put them in,
uh, just make, uh, you know, put them on
the, uh, comment section. And if you
have any other cars you want to see,
just let me